previously on J TR there were many many
things that JFK did that went completely
and utterly against the military
industrial complex he thought his number
one job as president would be to ensure
that a nuclear war never happened before
JFK was inaugurated he had been briefed
on a plan by the CIA to train Cuban
Exiles to invade Cuba to take back their
Homeland little did he know that the CIA
knew this Invasion would fail and that
the CIA was betting on him to send in
troops anyways once the invasion did
fail to save face only after the
invasion failed the jit K realized that
he had been drawn into a CIA trap JFK
realized that if he wanted a chance at
peace he would have to wage a different
kind of war against the very people in
his own government the cia's number one
enemy was now the commanderin-chief
President John F Kennedy one of JFK's
friends asked him what he thought of a
best-selling novel at the time about a
fictional military Takeover in the
United States it's possible he said but
it won't happen on my watch as the dust
settled JFK turned to one of his highest
officials in his administration
and said that he wanted to Splinter the
CIA in a thousand pieces and Scatter it
to the
winds after firing the three most
powerful men in the CIA JFK then started
cutting the cia's budget hoping to reach
a 20% reduction by 1966 and from then on
instead of relying on the CIA for advice
on foreign policy he made the military
joint Chief of Staff his main advisers
because he foolishly believed that the
military would be easier to control than
the CIA oh boy was he
wrong
one of America's most important
Battlegrounds in the Cold War was Asia
at the time the country La was being
torn apart by a civil war between
communist rebels backed by Vietnam and
the pro-american governments in other
words La was under the threat of falling
to the commies so guess what JFK's
military generals advised military
action of course La is a small
landlocked country they argued it would
be a piece of cake all JFK would have to
do was move a few thousand American
troops into LA and bomb a bunch of rebel
hideouts simple the military generals
argued but with the Baya pigs fresh in
his mind JFK was not about to fall for
that trick again a war in the remote
jungles of La would be difficult to win
and escalation would be all too easy you
drop a bomb on Hanoi and you start using
Atomic weapons Robert Kennedy remember
them replying to JFK it became Crystal
Clear not only had the CIA gone mad but
also the military it was obvious that if
he wanted a real chance at World Peace
he wouldn't just have to Splinter the
CIA he would have to bring the military
quote under under strict control as well
this has got to stop he told his
press secretary JFK had already painted
himself as the number one enemy to the
world's most powerful intelligence
agency and now it was time to do the
same to the world's most formidable
military and by the way guys if you've
ever thought about starting a a YouTube
channel but you hesitated because you
don't have a good camera mic or editing
knoow then you got to know about this
app called invid ai invid ai is like
chat GPT but for videos it allows you to
create full blow and ready to publish
videos using just text prompts meaning
that it will write the script for you it
will select the stock footage and it
will even record the voice over for you
check it out they're the sponsor of
today's video first you want to open up
the nid AI interface and you want to
type in your props you want to be as
detailed as possible so don't say
something like a YouTube short about
cats you want to say something like this
create a YouTube short on the craziest
facts about cats make it funny and use a
female voiceover with a Southern accent
click generate you can mess around with
these settings and then click continue
and you get something like this well
howdy there folks ever wondered why your
cat acts like they're the boss that's
cuz in ancient Egypt cats were worshiped
like Gods not bad for a first draft
where you didn't have to lift a finger
now you can make edits to it with more
text prompts something like this change
the voice over to a male British voice
and start the video with a joke about
cats now let's take a list of
all right folks here's a feline fun fact
that's sure to make you smile why don't
cats play poker in the jungle too many
cheetahs now that we've set the mood
let's Dive Right In ever wondered why
your cat struts around like own the
place pretty impressive and what's cool
is that you can also use nid AI for
educational content video essays
explainers so if you're ready to start
popping out videos without making the
videos yourself scroll down and click
the link below to sign up and try in
video AI for free you can make four
videos for free on their free plan but
if you're serious I recommend their $20
plan this plan removes The Watermark and
it gives you access to millions of
royalty free stock footage Clips you
also get a human sounding voice over and
much more so scroll down click the link
below and give it a try and thanks the
Nido AI for sponsoring this
video on October 14th 1962 a U2 spy
plane carrying out surveillance over
Cuba spotted something alarming Eight
medium range nuclear missile sites were
being built on the island Cuba didn't
have the skill or equipment to build
these missile sites themselves which
meant only one thing the sil iets were
on America's doorstep they were about to
move nukes into Cuba behind closed doors
the CIA and Military commanders must
have been Furious if Kennedy had just
bombed Cuba and sent in reinforcements
when they asked him to the first time
none of this would have happened cashr
would have been gone and so would the
Soviets chance of ever getting this
close to America Shores but now it was
too late Soviet nuclear warheads were
probably on their way to Cuba as they
spoke if they weren't on the island
already so the CIA and Military made the
only logical recommendation they could
completely destroy the missile sites
destroy Fidel Cash's Air Force 2 just
for good measure and if necessary the
military would obviously be on standby
ready to invade the island soon after
just to ensure the job was done but just
like JFK defense secretary Robert mnam
wasn't so sure about this aggressive
plan quot the military Chiefs responding
to mn's question about whether that
might lead to nuclear war doubted the
likelihood of a Soviet nuclear response
to any Us action End quotes that's right
if they attack Cuba the military Chiefs
doubted the Soviets would use nukes so
JFK was supposed to risk the future of
the world based on his military Chiefs
doubts and there was no way he was going
to play along so instead JFK went around
his military Chiefs altogether quote
Kennedy decided to impose a blockade of
Cuba without consulting the military
Chiefs with any seriousness he needed
their support in case the blockade
failed and Military stuffs were required
but he was careful to hold them at arms
length he simply did not trust their
judgment End quotes and so on October
22nd JFK addressed America this
government as promised has maintained
the closest surveillance of the Soviet
military building up on the island of
Cuba within the past week unmistakable
evidence has established the fact that a
series of offensive missile sites is now
in preparation on that imprisoned Island
the purpose of these bases can be none
other than to provide a nuclear strike
capability against the Western
Hemisphere but now further action is
required and it is underway and these
actions may only be the beginning we
will not prematurely or unnecessarily
risk the cost of worldwide nuclear war
in which even the fruits of victory
would be ashes in our mouth but neither
will we shrink from that risk at any
time it must be faced acting therefore
in the defense of our own security and
of the entire Western Hemisphere and
under the authority entrusted to me by
the Constitution as endorsed by the re
resolution of the Congress I have
directed that the following initial
steps be taken immediately first to Halt
this offensive buildup a strict
quarantine on all offensive military
equipment under shipment to Cuba is
being initiated All Ships of any kind
Bound for Cuba from whatever Nation or
Port will they found to contain cargos
of offensive weapons be turned back this
quarantine will be extended if needed to
other types of cargo and carriers we are
not at this time however denying the
necessities of life as the Soviets
attempted to do in their Berlin blockade
of 1948 JFK's military chiefs were
outraged hadn't he learned his lesson
the year before was he really trying to
talk the Soviets out of nuking America
the Soviets were barbarians they were
incapable of listening to reason one of
his generals even went so far to say
that quote this blockade and political
IC action is almost as bad as the
appeasement of Hitler at Munich End
quotes referring to the Munich agreement
signed by Britain France Germany and
Italy in 1938 before World War II in
this agreement these countries gave
Germany a large piece of land in
exchange for Hitler's promise to not
take any more obviously it didn't work
and JFK's generals were convinced that
his little blockade was about to go the
same way but what the generals didn't
know was that JFK wasn't just sitting
around doing nothing from now on he was
going to do things his way military
Chiefs be
damned
[Music]
while the military feed over JFK's
refusal to bomb Cuba the president
decided to take things into his own
hands JFK secretly reached out to Nikita
kushev the leader of the Soviet Union
hoping to convince him to remove his
weapons no one in the CIA military or
even the state department knew about
these letters and neither did kev's
people in one secret letter JFK wrote
the one thing that has most concerned me
has been the possibility that your
government would not correctly
understand the will and determination of
the United States in any given situation
since I have not assumed that you or any
other sane man would in this nuclear age
deliberately plunge the world into war
which it is crystal clear no country
could win and which could only result in
catastrophic consequences to the whole
world including the aggressor it was a
plea to the Soviet leader a warning that
JFK's military generals were a little
Trigger Happy in another letter JFK
wrote Whatever our differences our
collaboration to keep the peace is as
urgent if not more urgent than our
collaboration to win the last World War
him and kushev would go on to
communicate almost exclusively through
the Secret Letters At first Kev refused
to listen he refused to negotiate or
even consider removing his missiles from
Cuba but JFK wouldn't give up he kept
trying to make Cru see reason and
eventually he did on October 25th 11
days into the Cuba Missile crisis Fidel
Castro sent kushev a letter pushing him
to attack America first it was now or
never kushev was backed into a corner
before it had been all talk now here was
the Soviet Union on the edge of no
return and kushev just couldn't go
through with this on that same day
kushev reached out to JFK asking to work
together to resolve the crisis but while
JFK and kushev negotiated in the
background JFK's generals were getting
more and more anti was the president
just going to sit around waiting for the
Soviets to attack and then it
happened
[Music]
on October 27th an American YouTu spy
plane was shot down over Cuba and his
Pilot killed it sent the military into
overdrive couldn't that Kennedy see what
was happening the syet just took the
first shot it's time to attack there was
the feeling that the Noose was
tightening on all of us on a Americans
on Mankind and that the bridges to
escape were crumbling Robert F Kennedy
said the drums of War were picking up
pace but once again JFK refused instead
of declaring war on Cuba and the Soviet
Union JFK met with his brother Robert F
kenned and together they agreed that RFK
would have an emergency meeting with the
Soviet Ambassador and atoli doberan to
send the Soviets one final plea
according to crua Memoirs Robert Kennedy
told the Soviet Ambassador that the
president is in a grave situation and he
does not know how to get out of it we
are under very severe stress in fact we
are under pressure from our military to
use Force against Cuba we want to ask
you Mr de brinan to pass President
Kennedy's message to Chairman kusov
through unofficial channels even though
the president himself is very much
against starting a war over Cuba an
irreversible chain of events could occur
against his will that is why the
president is appealing directly to
Chairman kusov for his help in
liquidating the this conflict if the
situation continues much longer the
president is not sure that the military
will not overthrow him and seize
[Music]
power to Cru shf the message was clear
the kennedies did not know how much
longer they could hold out against their
generals so in crucia own words we sent
the Americans a note saying that we
agreed to remove our missiles and
bombers on the condition that the
president give us his assurance that
there would be no invasion of Cuba by
the forces of the United States or
anybody else JFK agreed and the crisis
was averted but that was just the
official story in secret JFK made a much
bigger concession JFK had promised that
America would remove all its nuclear
missiles from Turkey which was right on
the Soviet Union's border but America
wouldn't be able to do it right away to
save face Kush agreed and the US
military generals were never filled in
on any of this if anyone has ever
deserve the Nobel Peace Prize it was
Kennedy too bad that 13 months later he
would be dead
[Music]
later on it would become clear in the
eyes of the Soviets that the Soviets
probably felt that they had no choice
but to shoot down the you spy plane in
the book the limits of safety political
scientist Scott Sean talks about how
just 3 days before the U was shot down
the US armed 30 ICBM test missiles off
the coast of California at the time the
US was in Defcon 2 meaning that the US
was actively ready for fullon nuclear
war in less than 6 hours then the day
before the U2 was shot down the US
launched an unarmed ICBM test missile
off that Coast in California destined
for the Marshal Islands the Soviets
could have easily mistaken this for the
start of an attack and at the bare
minimum a dangerous provocation but the
one good thing that came out of the
Cuban Missile Crisis was that JFK got
the chance to talk to Cru shf manto man
world leader to world leader and as it
turns out the two leaders had a lot more
in common than they thought even though
the crisis was over their secret letters
to each other didn't stop in July 1993
21 of these letters were Declassified
and what they contained may surprise you
over and over again both JFK and kushev
agreed that the Soviet Union and America
needed a fresh start neither of them
really wanted another war in one of the
letters kushev wrote yes the Soviet
Union and the United States of America
must live in peace with each other they
must build their relations on the basis
of reason of due regard for the real
situation and of mutual respect on the
basis of the establishing of the
principle of peaceful coexistence
between states with different social
systems in international
Affairs this is the only right and sound
basis for cooperation and securing of a
lasting and stable peace it is my most
Ardent desire that it would not remain
only a dream and not become a mirage
that creates nothing but false hopes
both these world leaders wanted peace
but both these world leaders were
surrounded by a war hungry military 6
months after the Cuban Missile Crisis
JFK made good on his promises and
removed America's missiles in turkey and
when the military realized that JFK had
blindsided L with all of L they were
officially out for blood in their eyes
this young naive president had gone
Rogue he ignored everything they said
and had nearly cost them everything
hearkening back to JFK's prediction of a
military coup it was in this moment that
the military ERS probably thought to
themselves if we don't do something
about this Kennedy there is not going to
be an America left to save JFK had just
had his second Bay of
Pigs these brass hats have one great
advantage in their favor if we listen to
them and do what they want us to do none
of us will be alive later to tell them
that they were
wrong if JFK didn't know he was alone he
sure as hell did by now by making
enemies of both the CIA and Military he
knew he was on thin ice and so he
isolated himself he shut out all his
advisers both political and Military and
from then on he would only confide in
his brother Robert Kennedy but gfk still
had to talk to his advisers he still had
to have meetings with them to you know
keep appearances so he did but to
protect himself and to keep the record
straight he asked his secret service
agent Robert balk to bug the White House
yes bug it install hidden microphone pH
so the secret service agent followed his
orders and installed the White House's
first practical taping system
microphones were hidden in the Oval
Office and in the cabinet room with
hidden switches all around so JFK could
suddenly turn them on and off and from
then on in nearly every meeting JFK had
with his advisers he would put on a
smile and secretly press record in the
end there were 248 hours of recordings
in total including more than 20 hours
during the Cuban Missile Crisis and
these secret recordings revealed just
how little his own advisers thought of
him in one meeting in which JFK refused
his General's recommendations for a
quick and Powerful attack on Cuba the
moment JFK walked out of the room the
general started trash talking him qu you
pulled the rug right out from under him
one said as the other officials in the
room argued over how they were going to
get him to do what they wanted in
another meeting where a general L was
really pushing for an attack on the
Soviets in Cuba where he was really
reassuring JFK that the Soviets wouldn't
attack back JFK would later recount this
conversation with is Aid saying can you
imagine L saying a thing like that these
brass hats have one great advantage in
their favor if we listen to them and do
what they want us to do none of us will
be alive later to tell them that they
were wrong with these tapes JFK hoped
that he could finally learn enough to
finally reel in the military and CIA
again but little did he know that his
third Bay of Pigs was right around the
corner and this time it wasn't the
Soviets or the Cubans fault this time
JFK brought it all on
himself